I'm starting my vlog today solo 8:15 in
the morning had something canceled so me
and iris are on different schedules
pulling up to the office good day
got Nightline following me around today
so I'm excited about that so some of
your grandparents and parents are gonna
check that out on the television you'll
see that online I'll chop it up super
excited all great stuff focused
vaynermedia just a whole vein rx family
pure while all that is going extremely
well
tons of strategies for 2018 being
implemented super excited for agent 2021
our first owned-and-operated conference
in Miami next week that should be great
and obviously the book is right upon us
obviously super excited about crushing
it
it's doing extremely well in sales which
I appreciate YouTube YouTube YouTube if
you've not pre-ordered it now is the
time
[Music]
[Music]
well you know what a lot of people don't
understand about raising capital is you
just need somebody to say yes it's not
about you know here's how you do it you
you you keep there's seven people
running around right now that love
coffee
I'm tattoo or and tattoo and there's a
tattoo artist whose grandfather left him
or her million dollars and they're
trying to figure out where to spend it
those people exist like you're not gonna
go to Silicon like well the reason
everyone's losing is they want to go to
Silicon Valley and talk to bankers and
math kids and they run you through the
ringer and it's a waste of time you need
to go find entrepreneurial money who
believe in you you need to go find
somebody who sold their agency and has
12 million dollars now and is looking to
do something and as I go I understand
Mike and then and I love skateboarding
and tattoos and I love do you understand
like so I'm giving you a piece of advice
that people are just not understanding
that's the game like you don't go to
somebody who's gonna say no and that's
what every art it that's what every
creative you know entrepreneur is doing
right now and it's a complete waste of
time
raising capital it's so many of you've
gotten caught in this [ __ ] venture
capital and banking world when you want
to need money you got to be willing to
get it in any shape or form as long as
it's clean money and as long as the
person you're getting from isn't going
to put you emotionally in a bad place
right you know you don't want to you
don't want to get money from your aunt
who's then gonna text you 15 times a day
and say I hate you suck you know like
that brings in too much family dynamics
but nonetheless what I mean by that is
everybody's trying to fit into the mold
of how to sell to a venture capitalist
when that's like a moonshot instead of
trying to find high net worth
individuals who believe in your vision
like I I've never made it I've written
millions of dollars in checks through my
career and it's never been because of
the math and then other people have
never written a check that hasn't been
about the math and neither is right or
wrong
it's about styles and so you you know
but too many of you have no chance of
getting a Silicon Valley
venture capital firm to write you a
check and all you do is you sitting you
make excuses I didn't go to a good
college or I don't look the part or they
don't invest in minorities or whatever
you may come up with instead of going to
who will give you money
find who will give you money you know
high-net-worth individuals who are
creative and open-minded find them
I'm looking forward to hey thank you oh
yeah thank you
what kind of teenager wait I was a great
teenager my mom I'm writing a book
called perfectly parented so it's
interesting to hear what you guys so I'm
writing a book called perfectly parented
and it's the perspective of a kid who
feels his parents perfectly parented him
my mom and dad
so I ever did any I mean I did nothing
wrong except get bad grades so I I never
disrespected anybody I never did cliche
drugs and alcohol stuff I was I was a
nicest kid I was friends with everybody
in my high school I worked every minute
I went to like seven high school parties
in my life you know I just worked
I like helped around the house because I
was the oldest I was I was a
ridiculously good kid yet I wasn't like
a square or you know like meaning I had
fun I enjoyed it like my luck my high
school years were very simple I worked
every minute or right which was the
happiest moments of my time
whether it was doing baseball card shows
selling at flea markets or working in my
dad's liquor store or I was in school
being miserable I didn't play sports I
play tennis for two years but I barely
played sports I I didn't chase girls for
the most part like I just was very
focused on being an entrepreneur from a
very young age and I was obsessed with
not making my mom upset yeah you know
it's just true like I my mom guilted me
into being a great child and a great
teenager and I think that's what I do to
my employees by providing so much loved
and and support that the fear is letting
them down
guilty Irish was gonna leave after
working green for a year that was her
plan that was her thoughts but she's
still here because
it's better to be here than it's not to
be here well a lot of teenagers actually
disconnect from their parents because
their parents are screwing up their
parents are doing the wrong thing their
parents care about themselves not their
kids parents are struggling out there
because they're insecure and their
parenting their children based on the
judgment of other parents not based on
putting their kids in this position to
succeed I understand that
[Music]
get me on the phone with them for five
minutes
when was that this is like late middle
of 2016 okay took us a little bit of
time to figure out what our six cohorts
face in the city and is typical stuff
before we can only two ways to do that
it's a chicken and egg game you either
go out and get enough business that
allows you to afford it or you convince
people to work for you for free because
you know you're you're a good enough guy
that when you can make it whole you will
but there's a ton of twenty-two year old
you and me and Boyd's and irises there's
a lot of them there's just a lot of kids
who are 22 who want to [ __ ] with you you
just have to create the net so you have
to start put like people are scared to
ask for people to work for free but you
have to find two people who are working
here that are willing to work for $14 an
hour because you might have to pay
minimum wage I don't know what the rules
are here's why let me tell me I know I
know
let me tell you the secret of why I [ __ ]
with it yeah because I'm gonna pay them
back more and I know I'm capable of and
I know that if I wasn't capable of I
would die to the end like if this went
bankrupt cuz it was fraud going on and I
owed a lot of six of them dollars well
that's what I would work on until I
would start up again the biggest reason
people are scared to get asked people to
work for free is they
they think it's doing the wrong thing
and I think it's doing the right thing
there's a lot of street kids who are not
going to NYU who are going to a
community college that no agency wants
to hire because they're hiring from
better schools who you'll [ __ ] with and
they'll [ __ ] with you you might have to
kiss some frogs when you get free you
get what you pay for sometimes but but I
spoke for free
I've do stuff for free I did stuff for
I'm doing I'm doing stuff for free
constantly I'm doing this meeting the
[ __ ] is this meeting for me well I'm
good this is my version of working for
free like people you know when I talk
about working for free people love to
come out and [ __ ] kill me I know what
you guys are thinking they're just not
as smart there's two people on earth
right now who can be a designer or an
accountant or a media planner or
whatever the [ __ ] you do who are willing
to work for you for $15 because you told
them at you know a pop-up salad QSR are
for an hour that you'll [ __ ] it you got
them and they're gonna say you're brown
like me too it's always the ones that
look like you you know you know like
kids that went to Yale and went to MBAs
they don't [ __ ] with me until they break
at 29 then they find me of course of
course people especially back home right
yeah and since that was really at the
beginning of Instagram I started
organically growing a page just by
connecting with people and I know enough
about your like I know enough about that
era of Instagram to know that you were
on that wave I remember okay so fast
word to today pretty much you know I've
built this bridge
kind of on accident and but it's been
amazing so it's something that I'm
passionate about and I'm able to connect
with people on and you know I launched
the app December 17th so it's been just
a few weeks and so the launch was great
my community kind of just freaked out
exploded and they're loving it I would
just say that where we're at now is
we're pretty small team we're a team of
like five and the demand is like
exceeding like our potential as a small
team well let me let me give you a first
big piece of advice try to keep less
money of course
a hundred percent unless you're retiring
next year the biggest mistake that
people that go through what you're going
through right now make is they're trying
to maximize profit to buy the things
that the two of you want so they're
willing to not hire three more teammates
and invest in the business because they
want an extra vacation or a bigger
bedroom or three more handbags I mean
that's real the biggest first piece of
advice I would make is the following
there are Ming write min m/s pellet
there are 7,000 mins right now do you
help pump min is to do you know how many
like you have to wonder say how this is
all playing out mins a young woman Alex
like you know like iris there there are
people that are under 25 Alex way over
25 but there you are wow you look great
like but there's a lot of people right
now there's an unbelievable amount of
talented 22 to 24 year-olds who look up
to you who are willing to work for very
little you need to build out your team
and take it out of your short-term
pocket to create long-term success I get
I get 40 emails a week minimum Li of
like I have an MBA I've been running a
business for four years I've made and
forget about learned I've made more
money in the last six months watching
your blog and listening to your podcast
then I did the last six years with all
that background
because you have to understand this is
of the moment the reason they're so do
you understand that all of you in this
room don't realize how smart you are cuz
you're on your own bubble I mean this
you're in the forefront of something
which then means you don't understand
because then you're only surrounding
yourself with other people that are
doing the same thing 99% of the people
don't believe what's going on in
crushing it like when when I wrote the
first one the thought of making money on
YouTube or social media was absurd I
mean that go read the first day Amazon
comments of my first book nine years ago
so you've already got the mentality now
let me give you the practicality get
four people on your team for the cost of
what you probably allocated for one an
enormous amount of 22 year olds right
now and more next year because they're
getting affected in teenage years every
year more dream job in life is to either
be an influencer or work for one that's
just real thank you yes
yes enjoy I love I think you'll really
like it
there's I hope there's one or two little
nuggets that can you're so in it that it
will come natural but I really actually
wrote it for people like you like there
was like four to seven things that are
in there that I'm like okay this is the
best [ __ ] I know that I think maybe even
for the people that know they may not
know thank you guys take care bye bye
the reason this is intriguing is that
the streets will [ __ ] with me and so
it's got bigger upside this is why I'm
gonna go to the point that I want to
make which is when I think about
businesses like this the biggest thing
that I'm gonna give you a huge piece of
recommendation you don't want to be at
the mercy of these [ __ ] logos got it
nope I know exactly we're gonna say
here's the good news no here's why you
don't have the leverage I'm gonna say it
again it's way better if you guys design
something with a logo that was yours and
people started coming to you your
patents not gonna hold your brand will
it started as one it always works what
do you think Under Armour shard is what
do you think Mikey's started at every
brand were about to say started as a
single product company your business
book just came out yes yes yes working
with kids but do you understand that you
have a moment right now and you can
always go back to the classroom and
maybe never have a moment like this
again have you thought about that
because a lot of times I think people
think about selling out or changing
their lives but like what I love about
being a teacher and many other things
that people do I always remind people
just do me one favor know what you can
come back to and what you can't come
back to then you should go for it when
shit's good you go in the offense you're
crippled by opportunity my answer is if
you've got a good at home and she's
supporting you and the little ones not
gonna remember any of this anyway they
go take your moment it's easier easier
to give advice than to take it which is
why I think I've popped because I think
I only give advice that I already took
so nobody can call me down to
vulnerability I'm a practitioner of all
my thesis casey actually [ __ ] you know
what [ __ ] Casey Casey neistat's of
[ __ ] beast what he said where is he
where is he the name Gary Vee has become
synonymous with motivating an entire
generation no one understands the power
of social media better than Gary because
none of what he preaches his theory it's
an understanding born from his deep
expertise in business in life well Casey
understood about me and his quote for
this book is
my don't I'm not guessing I would have
regretted if I didn't take my moment
back in 2006 where I'm like wait a
minute am I in wine merchant or Amaya
anthropology like digital like what am i
I couldn't
I never knew the word in I wasn't a good
student so I didn't know all these words
that came to me later but I failed
forward I tasted and most of all I just
did not worry about what anybody else
thought go do your thing go just go do
it just honestly just go very hard yes
say yes to everything work until you
can't [ __ ] bleep and you know watch
all the things that I'm accepting but I
realize like you're saying the more
important focus is that yes you know
what you know what's what's up when you
say yes and you can't breathe anymore
because you're saying yes to everything
the yeses are giving you more oxygen
[Music]
the day's been [ __ ] crazy straight
[ __ ] crazy right yeah even by our
students okay you ready
do you think that there's destiny in
life I think DNA is a big [ __ ] deal
and I think has a whole lot to do with
how things play out and I think that
there are certain people who have DNA
traits that create scenarios that are
easy to see from far away this is a
matter here Cyrus SIA